one week after Hurricane Florence
slammed into the Carolinas the worst of
the flooding may still be ahead
the storms death toll has risen to at
least 42 people 11 rivers in the
Carolinas remain at major flood stage
some rivers in South Carolina still have
not crested Manuel Bojorquez is in
Conway South Carolina where the wacom a
river is rising man well good morning
good morning the wacom ah yep all eyes
are on it as you can see because it is
flooding that was the Riverwalk right
there and the fear is that more
catastrophic flooding and damage could
be on its way it's something this entire
region already knows all too well I
don't believe it's an act of God I think
it's just it's just nature Deborah
Jewell lives in New Bern North Carolina
one of the town's hit hardest by
hurricane Florence
she returned to find her home destroyed
by floodwaters and her backyard filled
with raw sewage I've been fighting not
say today in the lady next door to jewel
like many North Carolinians must now
decide where to go from here I'm
thinking now I don't know if I want to
do this anymore but I probably will stay
Andrew Bennett also lives in New Bern he
said there was nearly a foot of water in
his home and the mold is now growing
fast
we just remodeled this house last year
and now everything's ruined then it is
one of the few with flood insurance
according to a recent analysis done by
the Washington Post in Craven County
where he lives
roughly 10% of homeowners have flood
insurance and overall only about one in
ten homes in the counties hit by
Florence have flood insurance
I think hurricane Florence is a real
wake-up call for a lot of people
unfortunately John Mills is with FEMA if
you live near water and you don't have
flood insurance you are risking
financial ruin
some areas in North Carolina are still
inundated in parts of Pender County
emergency workers are using boats to get
around in Pollock's ville homes are
surrounded by water and in Goldsboro
some roadways and cars are still
submerged the damage will be in the
billions of dollars and in North
Carolina damages continue to be in
as floodwaters continue to rise the fear
is the same is true here in South
Carolina where the governor estimates
flood damage is already topping 1
billion dollars and could climb that's
because the wacom a-- is not expected to
crest until next week at possibly 3 feet
above its record gale boy so it
continues thank you very much man well